hi there steve kaufman
week one of my polish challenge is
behind me
uh i have been working very hard
uh the big event was my discovery of
real polish
uh where i found so much good content
because in language learning content is
king
it's not about teaching grammar grammar
information resources are available
anyone who's when you're curious and you
want to know about why something works
and stuff you look it up it's not a big
deal finding the good content is so
important
what pilter at um real polish has done
he has created a variety of content for
different levels but particularly for
beginners what he's done he's put up a
hundred stories
and each simple story
consists of a story told once then it's
told again with a different point of
view which might be a different person
or it might be a different
time like a different tense and then
this is followed by question and answers
lots of questions and answers you're
supposed to try and answer i don't
bother because i don't just an
imposition on me i don't like doing it
but i listen to it
and so
this introduces structures of the
language vocabulary in such a thorough
way
and of course the big thing is that
pyotr has a very pleasant voice
narrates these stories in a very
interesting way so it's like you're
captivated by it so this is excellent
beginner material lots of repetition
interesting sometimes when i'm doing it
on on my after i've gone through on the
computer linking the words i don't know
then i do it on my ipad and i look on i
link you can we can see it in the
sentence view so i look at each sentence
and try to see how the endings change
just a little bit of that helping the
brain to notice
and uh but then i just listen and i'm
reading and so i'm going to spend the
first few weeks on this basic material
i'm also doing some of his podcasts
which are more advanced
uh before i but already i can now go to
the radio the um polish newspaper and i
understand much more than i did before
and and this is an approach pyotr's
approach with it which is with this 100
stories i think it's so clever that i
would like to do it in other languages
where you just have 100 simple stories
and you tell it once then you tell it in
a different person or in a different
time and then you ask a bunch of
questions who did this why when
and this gradually subconsciously
introduces you to the language and then
of course beyond that then once you've
got a certain comfort level with the
language then you have to go after
acquiring lots of vocabulary but in any
case in language learning content is the
most important thing interesting
captivating meaningful understandable
content and i'll leave a link to real
polish in the description and thank you
for listening and oh i should point out
that in my first week my statistics said
link tell me that i have added
i think i've gone over 3 000 i've added
more than 3 000 words to my known word
list granted it's because i know
ukrainian and russian and czech to some
extent so anyway thanks for listening
and good luck in your challenge bye for
now